[Musique]
de bois d'arcy à elancourt elles
fleurissent malgré le froid de ce mois
de février les déclarations d'amour sur
les panneaux municipaux en ce 14 février
au petit matin david est venu s'assurer
que son mode où étaient bien inscrits
c'est la petite surprise de la saint
valentin
grâce à la mairie d'elancourt donc c'est
super original ça permet vraiment de
s'approprier la ville et les panneaux
qui sont souvent un peu sans sans trop
d'informations personnalisées donc voilà
bonne saint valentin ma chérie une
surprise originale lancée l'an dernier
dans cette commune et qui rencontrent
déjà un grand succès nous avons eu 25
élan courtois qui ont diffusé des
messages déclarer leur flamme alors
amoureux ou alors amoureuse et donc nous
les publions toute la journée sur les
panneaux électroniques et nous relayons
aussi l'information sur notre site
internet
évidemment sur notre compte facebook
instagram instagram et twitter david a
prévu de revenir ce soir en famille pour
immortaliser ce moment
quant à ceux qui n'ont pas franchi le
cap rien ne les empêche de profiter de
cette vague d'amour et de prendre part à
ces instants de bonheur
[Musique]